pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing company
dedicated to making the very best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built to wear
not to wear out visit gripsix.com pogchamps
wow well benji needs all the support you
can get because sardocia's rating is 14.50
what what have they been feeding this
guy oh i don't know i'm nervous but i i
really hope for benji oh apparently
he's a jungler this is so awkward
oh um never mind you'd like to take back
everything i said a lot of awkward moments here
i feel like it gets less awkward if
you just make it public right i just
put candy in my mouth it was like a weird
distraction yes black has the pawn chain
towards the center white devotes the bishop to
d3 so often when the bishop develops now is the
time that black takes because you don't get to
recapture in one move but the players are leaving
the tensions the sign that they've been improving
that they've been studying because i think when
you're less experienced you take as quickly
as possible when given the opportunity i agree
would it be what would you do next here well
the thing is not a single piece has been traded
so that's i would say the uh struggle right now
is what to do because nothing's been traded and
benji plays b3 to protect his sponsor with another
pawn and well sodor says i'm going to play h6
and they're actually playing a really high
level game this to this point taking on f6 would
unnecessarily give up the bishop pair whereas this
knight's not really going anywhere it can move
but then you're willing to trade the bishops
and this knight has nowhere good to move so
by not trading cutie they're leaving this tension
and creating difficulties for their opponent so
it's just not restricting their opponent's
chances to play something active perhaps a
trade here right because the bishop that's his
option he could take or he could just ignore it
so he does okay there we go we have a trade they
are recognizing that pieces can come off the
board don't need to keep them all proud of this
development one of the big things here cutie is
this pawn structure for white is really strong
and when you have a pawn chain the pawn chain is
only as strong as the base of its chain so the
f2 pawn is very safe so what black wants to do
in the near future is play e5 to start chiseling
at the pawn chain to create the bass closer to
black pieces and make it easier to attack it yeah
that's what i always do too i know you do you're
a stonewall player so you know about pawn chains
f5 you saw the engine drop and the reason why is
this pawn on e5 lost its defender so chest often
is about timing and now that black took this pawn
e5 is going to be one that can quickly get under
attack so rook takes f5 here will defend the pawn
temporarily but then this bishop can slide back to
c8 attack the rook and become useful for a change
you're right though bishop back was better the
rook on a7 would have protected but look at this
this pawn was under attack but now it's pinned
and if benji sees it bishop takes g6 steals a pawn
did you see benji he kind of threw himself back in
his chair i think he sees it fingers crossed okay
he's got his hand up he feels ready to play his
move he's down under three minutes sardosha had
the clock but that was a big swing if benji
takes that pawn he does he takes it nice okay
i am getting nervous for benji's time a little bit
i am as well and i think he's trying to figure
out because this bishop is hitting the queen and
the rook on the same diagonal that's a problem
for him he needs to see that his bishop can just
retreat back which saves the material and
still leaves black's king out in the open
uh we're spending too much time
and i i don't think he sees it
based on the time consumption no
i don't think he sees it either
that's the hardest thing and this is gonna
be very stupid and you guys gonna be like
yeah forehead cutie uh to remember is that your
your bishops can move back any sacrifice the rook
i actually don't think it's stupid at all i think
that's a mistake that is very commonly made one of
the hardest things to find in chess is retreating
night moves and treating moves in general are
easily missed all the time and now the problem for
benji is he lost a rook for a bishop he still has
attacking chances but the rook for bishop dynamic
should be good for sutter if he can handle this
well there but there's still pressure and i
don't think that sodos is out of the woods yet
i i think he's pretty safe to start playing oh oh
he did it no my gosh he did it he called it he's
being checkmated by force come on does he see it i
thought it was my analysis board for a second and
then i looked and no the engine's got he does
see it there he sees it oh gosh oh no queen f6
it's all forest it's all force it's mate it's it's
checkmate on the spot that's it's done and look at
foreign
i think 12. he plays fortnite and let's see when
the checkmate happens if we get a reaction look
how happy he is there he is oh my gosh but
i'm going to say i want sardosh to win now
because he was sad and i'm sad for him
so you really are flip-flopping here
yeah i feel bad when it hurts to lose in chess
it does it hurts it's not a simple it's not like
league of legends you can blame your jungler
all you can do in chess when you lose is blame
your coach and it doesn't feel the same whoa
whoa why the coaches got well i mean yes it's
always the coach's fault but why i felt i
felt like a sort of attack in a way i just
i just this is just it's just
hard i don't know it's just hard
yeah no i'm with you and i don't think that the
players i think they really have been appreciative
of all the coaching they've received and benji
right now up one nothing this is a london type
of setup the bishop drops back to g3 because if
black takes on g3 the h pawn replaces the bishop
and there's whoa look at benji fishy just blitzing
this out he's been working on this very clearly
and i'll look at benji he knows the plans this is
not someone memorizing an opening this is somebody
understanding because he brought his bishop
back to e7 he didn't like the pin here and
now you have the bishop on d3 you have the bishop
on h4 but lining up an attack is difficult because
one of the best ways to stop an attack is by
creating threats elsewhere in the board and with
this tension all over the place here in the center
white doesn't have a free hand on the king side
so much tension here cute you know what time it is
no i thought there could be a stonewall situation
with that pond going after that is not a stone
wall do you even know the stonewall that's not the
stonewall how dare you i asked you to teach me but
you're too busy teaching pokey and code mikko and
everybody else that's not the stone wall i'm sorry
i'm sorry gm's these days they don't even
know all the freaking openings that's crazy
i'm sorry embarrassing for you honestly oh oh
oh oh oh uh oh when pieces are in line with
the queen you go and try to pin them oh that
was a rush decision still a good position for
sardosh but go back a half step here rook to
c1 or queen to c4 you pile up and you pin the
piece and win the piece so this would have been a
great opportunity for starters to level the match
instead he takes on c6 and his idea is that
when the queen takes on c6 he will take on d4
white will still be a pawn ahead so it's a good
decision it makes sense but he had a move that
would have netted more material he did move that
really quickly yes and there are actually some
devious threats here that black needs to be very
careful about because i could see this ending in a
checkmate pretty soon for white here it goes after
queen takes queen takes a2 if you take this in
comes the queen of d8 with check and after king h7
there's knight e7 trying to bring the queen here
and checkmate this king and there's big
danger for black this could be very scary okay
let's see wait check okay 97. oh my gosh oh oh
no watch out here so the move that black should
play is push your f pawn because benji's queen is
actually eyeing the g8 square through the pawn so
push that pawn up the board oh wow and you can
save the day you can save the day here and look at
benji deep in thought what a cool mate i love any
mates with with a knight i think they're very cool
this you really don't see this very often but it's
because black's pieces are all out over there on
the queen side not helping the king and you're
asking you know when can you burn the king out
not in this position even a queen at night that's
enough material to land a checkmating attack
so this is very scary for benji he's
thinking he needs to push the pawn
i think that there's no other way to save the king
besides pushing the pawn up the board i hope he
sees it i don't i don't i i think he will just
because he surprised me a few times and you know
he's desperately looking right now you know that
he knows that there's got to be a way and he could
be thinking about pushing the pawn up to make
space for the king the problem is the queen will
stop on g8 then go to h8 and this king is going
on a walk up the board and actually checkmated in
the next move after queen takes pawn so let's
show that very quickly if h5 queen g8 up keep
check it's force checkmate there's nothing that
black can do and that would be a checkmate wow
let's see no move yet no move played by ben
oh he's got a minute come on veggie oh and
he's not streaming so we can't see oh oh no uh
it's gonna be this exact checkmate it's going
to be the checkmate here comes sodor sees
it no question he's going to do this mate
oh boy oh boy oh oh he blew the queen oh my gosh
oh my gosh you blunted the queen does benji see
it does benji see it benji do you see this oh he
has to see it look at benji's face he's in shock
oh he took the queen and sardosh loses the queen
benji is so confused no the tragedy not the queen
oh my god benji is smiling sardosa is melting
he's melting oh no sartosh played a great game
and that's so frustrating in chess you play a
fantastic game he was playing so well and on
one turn doesn't see the queen on the opposite
the board full board awareness needs to see these
things and unfortunately for sodos queens he is
laughing at himself he is laughing at himself
at least he's not crying well it's a botez
gambit for the ages and benji fishy wins
a great match by benji but did get the benefit of
that blunder there both of these players look like
serious contenders and benji fishy wins the group
two nothing in this match and we are back with
both players benji fishy wins two nothing over
sardosh both of you played amazingly well i have
to say that i think this was the closest match
and the best played match of the entire event
so benji i want to start with you can you just
tell everybody what you've been doing how much
you've been practicing and it is clearly paying
off uh yeah i've been practicing as much as i can
uh you know i've got like fortnite tournaments
but you know whenever i have spare time um i i
just really enjoy playing it's a this is a nice
hobby of mine i i just really enjoy and i want to
i'm a competitive guy so i want to get you know
as good as possible at it for sure and so does
what about you um every time i open twitch you're
playing chess or studying with a new coach seems
like you're taking this very seriously and you
did play great chess of course both games ended on
what's you know look like blunders on your end but
you were really playing well throughout my life
i don't know i uh first of all it was
one of my intense game uh i played for
my whole life so i wasn't used to be focused for
so long in a chess game for us at first and then
well i i'm a bit sad because i lost both game
boss game because of tactics i was supposed to be
slightly worse than benji concerning positional
stuff and close position because he used to
close the position and uh i used to open up i play
an open silent play well i couldn't play my stuff
and he trained he prepared very well
against my london system so i i was a
bit confused at first but i always managed
to get out of the first position better and
i get too confident i guess so i'm
super i'm super ashamed actually to
that i have done this mistake because i
already expected to win this tactic and
lose with strategy and i'm so sad man what the [
__ ] no you played amazing and i know obviously
the result stings but i have to reiterate
that time and time again you really played
excellent even in this moment i brought up
the boarder you're talking about positional
you